whenever I stand on the stage somebody
asks me
um how they can start a leadership
training program especially when they
don't have a big leadership budget and I
always say the same thing start a book
club well we've decided to do the work
for you introducing my optimism book
club super super excited about this
we've made it really fun we've asked all
the challenging questions and it's
designed to help promote the
conversation and more importantly the
education of what it takes to be a
leader it's all broken into easy
bite-sized chunks where your team will
come together and discuss a few chapters
every single week until the book is done
of course we're launching it with the
infinite game which I'm also super
excited about because I love that book
and I hope you like it check it out it's
really a great way to start the new year
and if you're in a leadership position
show your team that you care about
helping them grow as leaders check it
out let me know what you think until
then
take care of yourself take care of each
other